as soon as you write this down and you
think about going through this process
the first problem that leaves out at you
right way before you even attempt to do
the next line is that what I've given
you doesn't really match this this is
special this is Manik right what does
Manik mean again what it means that
let's introduce a bit more language
because your honor I told you many times
language isn't it's not like oh let's
make things hard to remember it's like I
need some language you talk about what's
going on here and if I don't have words
for this I can't write so let's talk
about a few things let's pair of acumen
it's a quadratic so I have powers here
right but one of the powers is most
important right and it's clearly this
guy to write the two is far more
important than the one I can take the
one away and it's to the quadratic this
one's got a power 0 I could take him
away Susilo quadratic what makes it a
quadratic is the highest power so we
call that we've we've learned this
language you forced that to the D the
degree right it's the highest power
there so therefore because the highest
power is the most important power there
the number attached to the highest power
is also the most important right so this
term here with the degree it's called
the leading term it leads the quadratus
why we put it first and their number at
the front it's coefficient the
coefficient of the leading term is the
leading coefficient in this case it is 1
and when it's 1 we call it a mana
quadratic right when you go to market
money quadratic you can complete the
square Manik all right but that's ok
because the right hand side is equal to
0 so I can make it money what do I do
/ it so that gets rid of the a there but
it adds it onto these guys which
normally would be a bad thing you would
say that's worse than where you started
okay but we have to stay with it in
order to actually complete the square
yes yes yes and we will get to those
this afternoon
all right so what I do with this I'm
going to this was the step that Nikita
suggested getting that constant over the
other side I will do exactly that
kick him over and while I'm at it since
I have a convenient gap there I'm going
to do the completeness we're still the
completing the squares that is this one
here carving and squaring having and
squaring and that's what I add on okay
so if I have this and then square it I
have it that gives me B onto a right and
I could square and expand in one go but
I'm just gonna leave that for now
because up I'll have plenty of things to
feed my head I don't want to screw up
the square okay so I add it there
I better add it as well happy times
okay now that I have the squared now I
have a square on the left hand side so I
can factorize it what do I have okay so
there's that perfect square on the left
hand side on the right hand side I have
some things I can simplify here don't I
okay so this guy is positive I'm going
to stick them out the front B squares on
4a squared if that's 4a squared and I've
got a C on a negative C on their hand
how do I change that fraction so I can
put the yellow
yeah if I multiply this by for a and
this by for a I'll have my common
denominator right so that's where that
guy comes from right you see where he
comes from he comes from trying to put
together those two fractions okay so now
I'm going to say this step because
that's where I'm up to I'm taking the
square root well I'll get left over the
right in silence
it's gonna be plus or minus the square
root of this whole fraction okay so far
so good
this guy he belongs on the other side so
we'll move him over and that's where
your minus B on to a control pause pause
might be on TV you recognize that don't
you - be on to a areas right there right
he's the answer secession now I hope you
can see algebraically why is the access
to century what is solving for what are
we trying to find we're trying to find
these guys we're trying to find these
guys now because we started off by
saying this thing is symmetrical right
there's your axis of symmetry BAM
and again to your two roots because it's
symmetrical if there's my axis of
symmetry I should go to the left some
distance and then I should go to the
right the same distance right those two
distances are the same and the distance
that they are is this
that's the distance between the axis of
symmetry and the Therese
the - takes you to that one and the plus
takes you to that one okay which is
exactly what we do is - okay we're
always there aren't we I can simplify
out I've got - be on to a plus or minus
because I have that plus or minus there
right the square root of a fraction is
the fraction of the square roots and so
I've got 4a squared at the bottom that
just becomes the suit a I don't need to
write plus or minus 2a because I have
the plus or minus already accounted for
you see that common denominator and lo
and behold the torture device for
centuries or students now that's a lie
hasn't been around that long
also monotype device isn't it insightful
it shows you so many things about this
right quickly now that we have those
let's just label these guys right
because they are different this one over
here is minus B minus the square root
and this guy necessarily is minus B plus
the spirit